if you want to make more money you want
to make big money you have to start
thinking on a bigger scale and that
might sound obvious as I say it but
recognizing your own limiting thinking
where you're playing small is one of the
most challenging things to do I think in
the world I am where I'm at because I'm
also I've thought big enough but also
I'm not at a higher level because I'm
not thinking bigger I was talking to an
Entre friend of mine and he's built he's
built a decent business inside of one
year he's got A4 million doll business
and he went from you know being let go
from his job and he messages me just as
a as a fun thing to do and like hey I'm
qualifying for one of the airlines to
get a certain level a certain tier with
them and I need to get a certain number
of points so that I can qualify to get
in and said oh I don't know I don't I
pay zero attention to that he's trying
to solve the problem of I need to get
into the Points Club so that I can I can
get whatever marginal benefits from
being in that club he's got a couple
client right now that if he could go and
visit them we were just on on a call and
he's talking about how one of his
clients is having a hard time figuring
out a standard operating procedure
instead of thinking about a points run
how about you go fly there and say you
know what I'll spend a day with you
sitting down training you on how to do
this you still get your points and
qualify for whatever discounts you get
and benefits you can fly business class
there have a much better experience and
end up doubling the business with your
client and getting an extra five six
figures as a result of it like this is
the upgrade in the thinking you want to
make bigger money you have to start
thinking about bigger thinking hey it's
Nina car Michael and we made these
videos because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
the push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan carmichel
and learn if you want to make big money
and you need to apply this
[Music]
enjoy and I fully acknowledge that I'm
not thinking big enough for where I want
to go you know every time I I think I'm
thinking big I'll watch a Grant Cardone
video or I'll watch an Elon Musk video
and Elon Musk is talking about having a
backup plan for the planet that's why
we're going to Mars I watch a Steve Jobs
video about taking a dent in the
universe and I realized oh my gosh I'm
thinking so small you know I'm doing
nothing not in a bad way in in an
inspiring positive way to say man you
could be doing so much more come on man
let's
go so it's still my biggest problem
too it's the hardest thing to catch
because for him and his environment and
his friends and how he grew
up a a points run is is correct thinking
you know getting the discount codes is
the the right thinking the challenge
with that is you're spending time
looking for the best deal and looking to
save $100 here or couple hundred dollar
there and you're using your mental
energy up on small
problems what my friend is doing is
using his mental energy up on trying to
save a couple thousand when he could be
adding six figures to his business with
the same mental
energy now
luckily you know he brought it up and I
was able to call him out on it and and
suggest a better path
forward if he hadn't it it was a joke I
think when he sent it like where would I
where should I go on a points run I
don't think he expected the answer that
I gave him but I think the only way to
to get this is to be around the people
who can call it out in you either
physically I think that's the best the
challenge is it's as you as you get
bigger as you grow more there's fewer
people who are ahead of you who can push
you right there's fewer people who can
look at what you're doing and say hey
this is nothing play bigger in a loving
way like push you in a loving way as you
climb the ladder there's very there's
fewer and fewer people at the top of the
ladder who are ahead of you right and so
yes you want to get back and you want to
serve and as you learn you reach back
and you pull somebody else up to your
level but constantly finding somebody
that's why I love um I love Mastermind
groups I love coaching I love tapping
into experts on different topics cuz
they pull me up uh even if I'm an expert
at something I want to talk to my
friends who are experts and people who
are ahead of me because they push me to
be better and if you don't know those
people yet what are your options well
you could join group programs right I've
got for example movement makers I love
my movement makers program it's 49 bucks
a month and we meet every two weeks and
you get to learn learned from me and
there's other amazing humans who are
trying to build up their platforms as
well and become thought leaders and
experts but if it's not my program
there's tons of other programs out there
who do you connect with who do you love
who do you look up to and you get a
little bit of you may not be able to
afford to fly there and meet them but
you can learn from them even in a group
setting if you can't afford that you
know 49 bucks a month or 97 bucks a
month or whatever the programs are is
too much for you then even the free
content even even what I'm doing even
these videos here you get a little bit
from some super successful person every
time I make a video if you even just
consistently watch those I've learned a
ton from Elon Musk and and uh Jeff Bezos
and Steve Jobs and people who I've never
met through my own videos and they push
me and they challenge me they can't
specifically call me out they can't say
hey Evan what you're doing right here
this thing that you're doing like the
points run is small right you shouldn't
be doing that but they can at least give
me encouragement and motivation in in
seeing what they're doing inspires me to
want to do something bigger rule number
two Focus the problem is not that you're
not a genius the problem is not that you
don't have great ideas the problem is
that you are not focused you haven't
said that this is the thing this is what
I have to accomplish today this is the
mission that I am on and nothing is
going to stop me if you don't learn to
focus on what's important to you you'll
never do important things and live your
life reacting to what's important to
other people instead so I recently
started a new business with one of my
thought Leadership Academy students
Jeremy he came to my event last year I
was thinking about him on my tour this
year and said I want to start a business
with Jeremy around YouTube Consulting I
get asked a lot hey Evan can you check
out my channel hey Evan can I work with
you hey Evan can I hire you for XYZ
looking at my channel giving me ideas
mentoring guiding me and it's just not
the business that that I want to be in
but it is a business and so I thought
Jeremy Jeremy's going to come on board
he's going to do it now when I recruited
him and called him he was not a YouTube
expert and I gave him the homework and
said listen if you want to do this
business together it's got to be
important to you I'm halfway through my
trip on my tour I'm coming back in a
month and a half here's what I need you
to know by the end of the month and a
half and I gave him resources I gave him
videos I gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this and then when I come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business and he did he focused he made
it his priority he knew nothing about
this and all of a sudden he became an
expert by every day all day long
grinding to learn by by researching
everybody who is an expert at this
understanding their methodologies their
best practices looking through all my
videos my thumbnails my strategies all
the things that I've talked about in the
past digesting it kind of like the
Matrix when Neo's in The Matrix and and
he now we can learn Kung food and now he
learns how to fly a helicopter all of
that stuff that's basically what he did
and when it came back in a month and a
half I put him to the test and said hey
let's do two free calls we'll take two
people from my community and say hey
free free call let's go and he blew me
away with how much he knew because he
focused on it here was a guy who went
from knowing almost zero to now being an
expert to be able to really help give
value to people and now when we're
looking at new people coming in
I I barely have to do anything because
he already knows what I'm going to say
he already knows he's already done the
work he's done the research because he
spent that time on focused effort and
this is where I think a lot of people
feel like they're never going to win
because you may not have had the
expertise you don't have the education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just focused work that you're
passionate about focused work you could
quickly become in a matter of months an
expert at something if you just focus in
on it and dedicate your life to that
thing that you love you can easily pass
people who are experts at something who
don't love their thing but because
you're willing to take it on you're
willing to absorb think about when you
went to school how much of the
information you had in your head but you
had to read over the page four
times you write the same page four five
six times cuz you got lost you got
distracted that's not focused work cuz
you don't love that thing but when you
love something how much faster do you
retain it
how much more enjoyable is the learning
process how much better are you really
quickly because you love doing that
thing and so Jeremy got really good
really quickly because he loved it
because he attacked it because he
focused on it because he made it a
priority because he didn't say well I'll
spend half an hour a week trying this
new thing no that's not how you
win now where do we go from here we'll
see does Jeremy want to be a oneman band
forever does he just want to be a high
paa consultant does he want to then
bring on a team does he want to expand
you want have products we'll see we'll
see how that business evolves and
flows but he got here in a really short
amount of time because of that Focus
effort and energy and that's what I want
for you I want you to take that big idea
that you have I want you to take the
thing that you have great ideas you're a
genius you are a
genius why are you not winning why are
dummies winning from the same ideas as
you from like a half big version of your
idea they're off winning cuz they
focused on it that's the only difference
the thing missing in your business's
success story is a lack of focus and a
lack of momentum I want to change that
I'm going to give you a three-step
process on how to do it step number one
what is the most important thing right
now like what is the most important goal
that you need to work on right now that
if you did this thing that you worked on
this thing it would it would potentially
have a big impact on your business what
is it you have a million ideas your list
of ideas is not going to get shorter by
the way as you get older you're just
going to add more and more and more and
more to your list of potential ideas
it's amazing but which one on that list
which one that if you just focused your
time that I said here's a gift of8 hours
go Crush something what would you pick
what's the most important thing to you
right now get clarity on it number two
is schedule for Success successful
people have schedules that support them
what is a schedule that you need to have
success is habits success is looking at
your calendar and saying if I did this
work what's in my calendar if I did this
for the next week am I going to move
closer to my goals or not am I building
momentum or not don't schedule according
to other people's goals schedule
according to your goals and put
everything in there how much time you
want to spend as a as a father as a
mother as a husband as a wife as a son
or as a daughter as a friend how much
time do you need for yourself how much
time do you need to sleep put it in
create your calendar this is your life
build your ideal life because if you
don't schedule if you don't have a sense
of like if I did these things this is
what's going to lead to my happiness and
my joy you're never going to get it
there's always going to be demands for
your time there's always going to be
something that somebody wants to pull
you in on there's always going to be
another pressure from the outside and
you won't have the strength to say
no because you don't know what you're
doing right it's easy for somebody to
pull you away move you off your rock
when you're not stable on your rock I
want you to have a foundation you're
standing on a pillar a rock that goes
right to the core of the earth that
nobody's pushed me from this rock cuz
I'm on a mission I'm going to accomplish
my goals this is what's important to me
to build the life that want for myself
my family my community schedule for
Success put into your calendar that one
most important goal that you have that
you laid out in in Step number one that
one most important goal you have to have
time for it every week there has to be
somewhere in your calendar where you
spending time on that if your goal was I
need to write a book a book's not going
to write itself you're never going to
magically have free time to do it you
have to block off time in your calendar
to make sure that it happens and step
number three is create an environment of
Excellence an environment of Excellence
you want to create an environment that
lifts you up that gives you motivation
that boosts you it's everything from
your physical environment look at look
at mine like these people are here on
the wall for a reason they may not mean
anything to you right you probably know
him and him and and most of you won't
know all the people in between there
that's okay they means something to me
they mean something to me this is my
environment of Excellence what's yours
when you walk into your office your
bedroom your basement wherever you're
working your
car does it boost you does it make you
come alive doing this setting this
office up is a one-time thing and then
every day I walk in and it's a reminder
it's a reminder to play bigger it's a
reminder to believe in myself more it's
a reminder to chase down Excellence it's
a reminder to not stay comfortable build
your own environment of Excellence also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three get attention
people often ask me what is your
business model Evan how do you make
money this is it this is my business
model I kick up as much noise in my
industry I get as much attention as
possible in my industry and then I find
ways to monetize it that's it when you
have a lot of attention in your industry
people will find you and throw
opportunities at you my biggest
challenge is trying to figure out now
which opportunity to go after I get
speaking gigs because of the attention I
built to my YouTube channel I get
opportunities to connect with people
like Tony Robins and have them being
interviewed on my channel I get brand
deals with people wanting to partner
with me I get book deals it everything
has come because of my YouTube channel
because I built up a quarter of a
billion views because I have 1 Point
whatever million subscribers I just kick
up a lot of attention in my industry and
then deals come to me and that works
really well for someone like me because
I'm introverted because I'm much better
at marketing than I am at sales and so
instead of me spending time which would
be more wasted time going out trying to
connect with people trying to reach
people because I'm introverted I just
get to work on creating amazing content
and I have people then find me and
findly me out the places and pay me to
do things because I built up the
marketing attention machine and so if
you want to do that as well I'm going to
give you a seven-step process that I use
every single time for whatever platform
I'm going after that you can win and
model as well okay step number one is
you have to decide to get attention you
have to decide you have to say I am
going to go out and get attention
because all the strategies that I'll
give you and others will throw you as
well will not work unless you've decided
there's a whole bunch of people who have
made it in the offline world that now
come to me and say hey Evan can you help
me blow up online and say yes I'm happy
to help I love your message but you have
to be committed to doing this this isn't
just some strategy that's going to help
you you have to be committed to be able
to make content and that you are picking
a platform that you're going to blow up
on and you're going to be committed to
doing it it's not just some strategy you
got to love it you got to be all in you
have to decide I am going to blow up on
this platform and so number one get out
of your own way get out of your ego it's
not about you blowing up personally
because you want to look like a rock
star understand that the more that you
blow up the more that people understand
your story this is your gateway to close
sales because the thing that'll make you
different than the big corporations why
am I going to hire you why will I work
with you and set up some big Corporation
big Corporation they have a history they
have a reputation they have a brand name
they've been around forever why am I
going to work with you because I know
your story because I like you because I
feel like you care not some giant
Corporation but if you don't tell me
that if I don't feel that if you haven't
blown up if you're not deciding to get
attention then I'm never going to know
the difference between you and giant
Corporation and then I'm going to make
my decision only off of price and if
your strategy is to be the low price
provider that's a losing game long term
and so step number one is you have to
decide that you are committed to this
year I'm going to get attention because
it's the best thing not just for me it's
the best thing for my business it's the
best thing for my family it's the best
thing for my community and it's the best
thing to further serve my mission it's
not about you and your ego it's about
the mission and the business and your
family you need to get attention step
number two is pick your best platform
there's lots of different platforms out
there the one that you should go with is
the one where number one your audience
is so if you're picking a big platform
like YouTube or Instagram it serves a
big audience if you have a specific
audience so if you want to do business
then you can go to LinkedIn right if you
want to do the Tech Community Twitter is
going to be a better bet for you if you
want to Target pre-teens then you want
to be on Snap depending on what your
Market is where your audience is you
want to pick your platform then you want
to pick what are you the best at doing
so I love making videos so YouTube is a
great platform For Me Maybe you love
writing maybe writing is your preferred
method maybe you don't want to be in
front of a camera great maybe you love
audio and so you'd rather do a podcast
than make a YouTube video great when you
can figure out where your audience is
that also matches with your skill set
then pick that one social media platform
and go all in on that one people often
say well you got to be everywhere you
got to have all your accounts I disagree
at the start I think you should have an
account on each Platform One just to
have the account just so that nobody
else can take your name and squat on it
and and ruin your reputation potentially
and two just to listen so if Twitter is
not your main platform but somebody
tweets at you you want to be able to
respond and you want to encourage them
they're your Champions they're outs
spreading your message for you but if if
you try to be everywhere all at the same
time at the beginning when it's just you
doing it every platform is going to suck
you're going to do everything in a
really mediocre way I'd much rather have
you focus on one platform go and crush
it Go and dominate it and as you scale
up and build a team then you can go and
Branch out to the other ones so pick
that single best platform for you step
number three commit to posting every day
every day you have to post every single
day whatever platform you're on you have
to commit to posting every single day
YouTube is probably the platform where
you can get away with not posting every
day but I post three times a day and yes
I built my team that's helped me be able
to do that and yes you me not be able to
do it right from the beginning but that
is your ambition I want you posting
every single day whatever you're picking
YouTube Instagram LinkedIn snap Facebook
Pinterest wherever you're going if you
are posting every single day you have a
much bigger chance of getting attention
of getting your message to spread than
if you're posting every week or every
two weeks or once a month and then you
might say well I want the quality the
quality has to be high right it has to
be good I don't want to release crap yes
100% but if you can get to the point
where you are releasing 80% quality
every day instead of 100% quality once a
week do the 80% now if it's going to
come down to 50% quality now we've got
an issue but if you can release at 80%
and do it more frequently you will grow
you will blow up you will get more
attention and your mission will be
served you will reach more people you
will sell more you will get more
attention and start to win harder you
need to at least get on the map get on
the path have a vision to be to posting
daily that is in your mindset you are
building the business that you can post
daily whether you can do it right now or
at least it's on your game plan you
can't be stuck in posting any less step
number four is learn how to create great
content I get so many people who write
to me and say hey I going to making
great content but I'm not winning what's
up how do I get better how do I promote
myself more chances are your content's
not that good
listen I'm being honest your content is
not that good first step for that is
watch your own content back would you
consume you would you would you watch
your video of your message and say wow
that was really good like watch your own
content back would you subscribe to your
channel and if the answer is no then
that's a big problem you have to make
content that you are proud of and you
have to learn how to do it and I'm a big
believer that the quantity leads of
quality that the more you do if you
commit to posting daily you will figure
out how to get better really quickly if
you're only posting once a week it's
going to be hard to get really good
quickly because it's just taking you too
long if you're trying to learn French
and you go to class once a week you'll
just learn so much slower than if you're
going every day right so you need to
learn how to make great content and
don't default the thinking that you're
making great content you deserve to be
where you're at somebody has seen your
content and they haven't shared it you
guys are watching this video some of you
will share it some of you won't the ones
of you who share will think this is
great and the ones of you who don't
won't I need to get better better right
the content's not good enough I need to
improve my skills I need to be a better
Communicator I need to get to the point
faster I need to have more energy
there's lots of things I need to work on
people who say I deserve to have 10
million subscribers on my YouTube
channel I don't I'm not good enough the
content's not good enough now I deserve
my 1.7 I deserve to be where I'm at I'm
not garbage right but I don't deserve to
have my 10 and so you don't deserve
anything you deserve to be where you're
at people are watching your content
every single day hopefully but they're
not sharing it that's on you it's never
been easier for them to share it they're
not doing it cuz it's not good enough so
default not to some marketing tactic or
strategy default to how can I get better
at the skill of making amazing content
step number five is listen and respond
to every single comment I believe that
every comment should get a response it
doesn't have to be you doing it every
time at the beginning it probably should
be so you can learn and taste and see
how people are reacting to it as you
grow though you want to have somebody on
your team managing your comments just
like in every every other customer
facing part of your business right if
somebody is calling your store if you
sell flowers and somebody's calling your
store you want somebody to pick up and
talk to that customer right if
somebody's emailing your store and
saying hey I'd like to buy something you
want to give them a response right
somehow in the world of social we've
decided that it's okay to ignore our
customers it's okay not to respond how
most people do it is at the beginning
they say okay I'm going to respond to
every comment great no problem it's easy
cuz you're getting one comment a day
that's super easy but as you build up
people will then say well I'm only going
to respond to the important people I'm
only going to respond to the people who
have a certain number of followers or
I'm only going to spend an hour a day
responding the
comments just hire somebody like you
would for every other part of your
business that's customer facing
everybody needs a response but it
doesn't have to be you doing it when you
respond to somebody on YouTube as an
example they're seven times more likely
to subscribe you're asking for people's
attention right you're asking for them
to care about you but you're not
spending any time caring back about them
the amount of people who want to grow
their their channels on any platform but
they're spending zero time in their
comments you're
losing and so I'm probably the only one
at this size who's really hardcore about
responding to comments and have hired
somebody to do it I just think it's
important I think if you're not
responding to every comment you're
leaving free subscribers free attention
on the table just go for it it's so much
easier step number six understand the
hacks of each
platform 80% of success comes back to
step number four which is learn to make
great content that's 80% of your success
80% of your success is coming down to do
you know how to make an emotional piece
of content that makes people feel
something and then move into action the
other 20% is understanding the hacks so
for Instagram hashtags means a lot for
posting Stories versus pictures versus
videos there's different strategies for
each one going to YouTube hashtags don't
mean anything but the thumbnail really
matters a lot and the title really
matters a lot what you put in the first
15 seconds really matters a lot there
are hacks for each platform and you get
get it by tasting it and you also get it
by learning you can learn all of this
stuff you can model success you can
watch tons of videos of experts talking
about these things so understanding that
last 20% really matters but you have to
this is where people fall down this is
where people make so much mistakes on
getting attention you're only focus on
the hacks and then you lose cuz your
content's not good enough 80% of your
success will be in the content still and
then 20% in the hacks if your content's
not very good the right Instagram
hashtag is not going to save you if
YouTube video isn't very good the right
thumbnail isn't going to save you always
default first to my content sucks I need
to get a better now sucks and relative
terms it sucks compared to where you
want it to be that's how it sucks but it
still may be really good for the people
who are serving you just want it to get
better you want it to keep getting
better every single time so step six is
understanding the hacks of each platform
diving deep into each one learning from
experts and playing around with it to be
Best in Class on that platform so if I
look at YouTube as an example for me it
took me 10 years to get the 1.7 million
subscribers on Instagram I went from
6,000 to 100,000 in a year really only
spending half of that year pushing in
hardcore because I understand how to
make the content I understand how to get
attention with great content what I had
to understand was the hacks of each
platform right I had to understand what
a one minute Instagram video would look
like I'd have to understand what a
picture looks like versus the videos I'm
used to I have to understand how to do a
15-second story on Instagram and use the
right hashtags to bring people in those
are the hacks but I understand how to
get attention and so it's so much easier
to grow to the next platform and the
next platform and the next platform
because 80% of it is exactly the same
and in Step number seven is love the
algorithm updates whenever there's an
algorithm update it's crazy how many
people complain so many people are
complaining like H YouTube changed their
algorithm H Instagram's changing their
algorithm whenever I see that I'm so
happy I'm so pumped this is your chance
to win if YouTube updates the algorithm
this is your chance to win because
because all the people ahead of you who
are complaining aren't going to do the
work to figure out the new algorithm cuz
they wanted to go back to what it was
before and check out how many times any
of the major social media platforms have
ever reversed an algorithm update almost
never and so while those people are
complaining and they're upset that they
lost all this attention it's not going
back to the way it used to be so let
them sit there and complain while you're
over on this side crushing it anytime
there's an algorithm update love it
learn to enjoy it go dive deep on all
the new things that are important to
that update and then apply it so you can
quickly pass all those people who are
complaining who are ahead of you rule
number four develop discipline
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact and to grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline there's
just a lack of follow through it's the
constant start and stop and start and
stop and start and stop and for me
there's nothing
more not just frustrating but sad than
seeing somebody who's got so much talent
and so much potential and so much of a
heart and just seeing them not win
because they're not following through
because you're just not doing the
consistent enough work that you're
motivated and inspired and then and then
you're not anymore and nothing happens
and one of the only things that saved me
the only re one of the only reason why
I'm here making these videos and you're
watching and I've had any you know
success in social media is because I
just was disciplined that I just kept
making videos one of the things I love
sharing is my journey of YouTube because
I was not an overnight success
story uh every month almost I'll I'll
post a uh my socials of how I grew month
over month year over year on on YouTube
and in the first 5 years I had 7,000
subscribers or so so 5 years in 5 years
in of making content 7,000 subscribers a
lot of you are already ahead of that a
lot of you could get there a lot faster
than me you know how do you keep going
when you're not getting traction when in
year one you have 100
subscribers I I just had the discipline
to keep making content to keep following
through and 12,000 videos later here we
are and and people can get there faster
you don't have to be as slow as me you
know I took I took a long time and I had
a lot of issues I was shy and insecure
and introverted and felt like you had to
be you know type A personality to win
and all of these all of these limit
believe all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires this discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me I remember sitting down at
a um Florida outlet mall and I was
sitting there with uh with a friend and
nah was going shopping and uh we spent
half an hour at a at a Starbucks there
while she was shopping and he said I'm
going to be the next Gary ve of my
industry you know in music I'm going to
be the next Gary ve in music and uh
you're going to keep doing your thing
like let's me you know let's let's keep
in touch and see how we do and how we
grow and he posted you know three or
four years later on his Instagram and he
said you know three or four years three
or four years ago I met Evan kle at this
Outlet Mall in Florida he had our
picture as the as the post and I told
him I was going to be the next Gary VE
for music and he's going to do keep
doing his thing and and Evan went on and
did his thing and I stopped and I didn't
have the success that I said I was going
to have and here's the thing this guy
has way more Talent than I do and he's
super talented in music and just better
camera
presence more
energy uh more his videos just look
better way more attention to detail he
had all of this stuff and and like a
warm amazing human who cares and wants
to serve and wants to see musicians make
money and turn their art into something
amazing right like he had all of this
stuff all of
it the only thing he lacked was
discipline and he didn't follow through
and and I see that in so many of
you you've got everything you've got all
the
ingredients it's just a lack of
discipline and not making enough it's
the it's the lack of because you're not
motivated you stop and lack of
motivation isn't a good enough reason
you have to follow through rule number
five the last one before our very
special bonus clip never give up Paul
Newman the legendary actor had an
amazing quote that I love to repeat he
said I check my pulse and if I can find
it I know I've got a chance you've got a
very important choice to make you either
make the rest of your life the best of
your life or you settle for what is and
live in your excuses so you know why I
would give up you know what I'm deeply
afraid of I've got two I've got a
short-term fear and a long-term fear my
short-term fear is of disappointing
people my biggest shortterm in the-
moment fear is disappointing people that
I would show up to an event and let
people down that I wouldn't give them
value that people would come and waste
their time spend their money and I
didn't give them value I'm I'm deeply
afraid of it and still am I put pressure
on these videos I want these videos to
be great every time I get in front of
this camera and start making a video I
put pressure on my myself that this
needs to be the best video that I've
ever done I want to not disappoint you
guys every single time and this little
pause hesitation before filming and I'll
I'll spend a couple minutes
procrastinating because I'm I'm afraid
I'm afraid of disappointing you in
making a crappy video I'll procrastinate
and then I'll do it and I'll feel great
at doing it but my biggest short-term
fear disappointing people my biggest
long-term fear is of regret is that I
won't live my life is that I'll look
back and say I could have done more I I
should have pushed harder because you
rarely regret the things that you did
it's the things that you didn't do the
things you were too afraid to do the
action is not taken that's what you
normally regret and so my biggest
short-term fear is disappointing people
my biggest long-term fear is fear of
regret and those things they fight each
other right they fight each other
because if I'm afraid of disappointing
somebody I'm not going to take the
action that I should be taking and then
I'm going to regret it later on and so I
try to use that P potential regret right
to push me into action to say if I don't
make videos today if I don't do that
speech if I don't get up and make that
presentation if I don't do the thing
that I'm afraid to do because of
disappointing people potentially then
I'll regret it and I'll put the pressure
like this is the video this video right
here this is the video that's going to
blow up everything that'll change the
whole game for me and if I don't record
it because I'm afraid of disappoint in
somebody I'm going to regret that my
whole life and I make it so painful for
myself that then I have to act and that
pain pushes me into action and out of
procrastination mode so if that's you if
you're afraid to take action if you're
thinking about giving up I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is what
I call the pillow test the pillow test
is this before you sleep tonight before
you put your head on the pillow this is
going to be you tonight you're having
great dreams you made amazing progress
you're building an amazing world you
love your life right before you do that
tonight before you put your head on the
pillow you have to do something that
will make you proud TR that's what I
tell myself every day today before I go
to bed I need to do something before I
hit my pillow I need to do something
that makes me feel proud of myself and
this is something that only you can
judge you might get some small victory
and post it on Instagram and get a bunch
of adoration and congratulations but do
you feel great about it cuz that's all
that matters how do you feel about
yourself is the entire game did you do
something even if it doesn't work out
even if you don't get results it didn't
work are you proud of yourself for try
that's what I want every single day you
do the pillow test before you lie down
before you go to sleep before the head
hits the pillow are you proud of the
effort that you put in Step number two
is what will you regret what will you
regret when you're when you're 95 years
old when you're you know at the end of
your life it's over what would you look
back and say I wish I wish I did this I
wish start your sentence with I wish I
wish I what when you're 95 years old and
feel the pain and and the heaviness of
that that you could have done something
that you were great you your Michael
Jordan level Talent at something but you
didn't do it because you were afraid
what is that
thing and now the great thing is you
still have a chance you still have an
opportunity you're not 95 you're not at
the end right you can still do something
and take action on it if you can fast
forward that much and actually feel the
pain it'll give you the strength
confidence more motivation to actually
go off and do the thing I hate regret I
want to live my life with as few regrets
as possible and that means standing up
to my fears and your fears and the
things that are holding you back from
taking action and step number three is
commit to someone immediately commit to
someone immediately as soon as you get
an idea you have this bold vision for
yourself I believe that the ideas that
come to you when you're feeling bold
confident powerful Unstoppable are
actually the right ones for you and then
your head talks you down from doing them
your head plays small your head only
understand understands the world that
currently exists so it bases decision
based off of logic and then you don't do
the thing as soon as you come up with
that idea commit to somebody else you
have to go then do it because you may
let yourself down but you won't let
somebody else down when you say I'm
going to show up to that gym and be
there I'm going to go and do that
workshop with you we're going to book
that ticket and go see that event you
may not show up if it's only you but you
don't want to let somebody else down and
so use that to your advantage the next
time you come up with an idea commit to
somebody immediately
maybe it's for tomorrow next week or
next month whatever but you're
committing to them so you have to follow
through this is why it's so important
that you love what you do it's why it's
the number one rule for Success that
comes up over and over and over and over
again is people love what they do the
people who are winning at the highest
level they love what they do that allows
them to be relentless cuz you can talk
about being relentless and giving it all
you've got and going all in and grinding
and giving
110% but if you don't love it you're
going to quit it may not be after a day
may not be after a month may not be
after a year but you're going to quit
when it gets too hard and you don't love
it you will quit this is why so many
entrepreneurs fail because you're just
chasing an opportunity you're just
looking at the fastest way to make a
buck in 2019 in 2020 in 2021 the fastest
way to make some money you're going to
give up unless you love it now money is
important it's got to be in your top
five but it's not number one it can't be
number one if money is your number one
you're going to fail you just won't put
in the work the people who win have
something that they put above money and
that's what allows them to wake up and
be relentless and put into the work
you're looking at a guy here who sucked
at making videos you can go back on my
channel you can watch the First videos I
was nervous I was shy uh I still am an
introvert but it's through practice
through being relentless I've had my
channel for 10 years I've made five or
6,000 videos across my four more than
four now nine or so channels 5 or 6,000
videos that's crazy right that's crazy
who does that you have to love it it
doesn't feel like work making these
videos is fun for me still 10 years
later is still fun for me I'm excited
the second that it gets to be oh I got
to make videos that's it I I'm out
because the people who love doing it
will crush me I was looking at my
YouTube thumbnail uh examples I'm I'm
doing a YouTube course right now where
I'm teaching people how to have success
on YouTube how to get your first million
subscribers get where is it get get get
there that gold button get one of those
for you right you're a thought leader
you're an expert I want you to get a
million subscribers that's that's the
course that I'm launching right now so
I'm looking at my thumbnail experiments
I have
130 thumbnail experiments happening
right now on my channel I'm testing 130
different variations then I went to
completed and what what we've completed
and gone through 1100 something
completed thumbnail experiments just on
thumbnails just testing my thumbnails
we've done over 1,00 different
experiments that's crazy right testing
big changes like not having text on a
thumbnail and making it purple and crazy
colors to really little tiny changes
like what if we just tweak this person's
eyes what if we alter the shade of
orange just little tiny changes that
most of you probably never
notice why I love it I can't help
it I love I wake up when I think about
this stuff and that's what I want for
you that's what you need to be doing and
it can't be forced Jerry seld calls it
the torture that you can endure the
torture that you can endure most people
talk about passion and purpose which is
great but it it's torture for other
people me stepping into Ed schedule
should be torture for me because I don't
want his life I don't want to do what
he's doing it should be torture how much
he's working how much he's grinding how
much he's chasing down his vision should
be torture for me and same thing the
other way him stepping into my schedule
and filming 6,000 videos and doing the
work that I'm doing split testing
thumbnails and making content for you
that should be torture for him if I step
into your life it should be torture for
me if you're an accountant and I stepped
into your life I would hate my life and
no matter how much I listen to videos
that said be relentless and keep going
and push through I would quit I would
hate my life so much that I'll never be
great at doing this thing don't be an
accountant if you don't want to be an
accountant you've got to chase down and
find the thing that you love you got to
do the things that give you
energy and that's the big takeaway
look at what is giving you energy look
at the activities the people the habits
the work that doesn't take energy away
but it lifts you up if I'm talking to
entrepreneurs it gives me energy as the
night goes on I only get better when I
do my Thursdays of of public facing day
of meeting people and doing podcasts and
interviews and workshops I only get
better with time helping entrepreneurs
gives me
energy pay attention to what gives you
energy pay attention to to the people
that give you energy and surround
yourself with them more pay attention to
the activities that give you energy and
do more of that doesn't mean you
necessarily have to go and quit your job
and and and burn the boats and cut all
your ties and go all in you don't have
to but make progress if every week you
made a 1% 2% 3% 5% Improvement in the
activities and the people that lift you
up and give you more energy man your
life in a year is going to be
dramatically different dramatically
different compared to where you are
right now you have to be relentless and
it comes only by doing work that you
love and gives you
energy because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch Evan's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
you'll never crush it on your podcast if
you show up every day and you don't like
the podcast you don't like the guest you
don't like what you're doing which means
you have to Pivot it may mean you I
don't know the backstory behind stopping
we do hard things and moving to